[Musik]
gegen korona geimpft und seitdem krank
zu keinem anderen thema haben wir mehr
zuschriften bekommen als zu diesem in
den vergangenen wochen nimmt das ernst
fordern sie die zuschauer macht das zum
thema spricht darüber okay das machen
wir in dieser sendung wir stellen die
richtigen fragen zum thema corona
impfung zum thema corona impfung
nebenwirkungen und das tun wir mit
diesen gästen hier im studium mit
jessica hat nämlich die rechtsanwältin
ist und sie spezialisiert hat auf corona
verfahren wir tun das mit klaus stöhr
dem top epidemiologen und neuerdings
auch mitglied in dem beraterstab
expertenrat der bundesregierung bei uns
ist eva putzen die leistungssportlerin
ist und krank ist seit ihrer impfung wie
sie sagt und bei uns caroline preißler
fdp-bundestagsabgeordnete bekannt
geworden in ganz deutschland durch ihr
corona tagebuch und dadurch dass sie mit
querdenkern ganz offen bei den
demonstrationen in die diskussion
gegangen ist in allen herzlich
willkommen frau putzen ich habe das
gerade schon gesagt sie betreiben
leistungssport ganz kurz einmal erklärt
was machen sie genau das nennt sich
kraftdreikampf da macht man einfach
kniebeugen bankdrücken und kreuzheben
einmal auf maximalkraft einfach ist das
nicht verdammt schwer ist das zu können
das heißt sie sie leben von ihrer kraft
sie leben von ihrem körper und das
können sie aber men so nicht ausüben
seit wann es fing an nach der zweiten
impfung mit astrazeneca da
hatte ich vier wochen so ein bisschen
herz stechen und lohnen probleme aber
beim training vor dieser impfung mehr
also sozusagen für sie guten alten
zeiten als die voll bei kräften waren
also dann diese nebenwirkung nach der
ersten impfung erst mal vier wochen und
dann haben sie sich auch noch pusten
lassen ich genau genau ich war vor der
booster impfung allerdings nochmal fünf
wochen ähnlich erkrankt wo auch kein
arzt wusste okay was ist da jetzt
eigentlich los was ist das problem habe
dann aber auch mit dem impf natürlich
vor ort gesprochen und habe ihm das
erklärt dabei meint es sei halt kein
problem und deswegen könnte ich mich als
booster lassen
und quasi am tag nach der booster
impfung habe ich schon gemerkt so ok
irgendwas stimmt da ganz und gar nicht
und dann war ich doch einen monat mehr
oder minder normal arbeiten schon quasi
gar nicht mehr trainieren und dann wie
lange ist das jetzt hier die booster
impfung waren 212 letzten jahres ok also
das ist schon wieder ja ein halbes jahr
her dass sie jetzt nicht bei kräften
sind also in geht es ganz offensichtlich
nicht wahnsinnig schlecht aber sie
können einfach ihren sport nicht ausüben
sie können nicht so leben wie vorher
richtig korrekt also ich bin ich war
dieses jahr ganze vier tage arbeiten
ansonsten war ich wirklich nur zu hause
bzw auf tour zu ärzten zu kliniken
ich kann sagen dass es mir mittlerweile
schon wirklich etwas besser geht aber
ich hab halt tage da kann ich das haus
nicht verlassen und ja eigentlich bin
ich nicht mehr selbstständig lebensweg
armen sie wissen sie haben sie ja einen
klaren hinweis darauf der zeitliche
bezug wahrscheinlich dass das so klar
mit der impfung zu tun hat die
beschwerden die sie haben also für mich
ist es klar
ich wüsste halt nicht den anderen grund
weil es zweifach den zeitlichen
zusammenhang einfach gibt und ich vorher
keinerlei der probleme hatte die ich
jetzt habe frau preißler sie sind fdp
bundestagsabgeordnete hat die politik
bis zum heutigen tag alles getan um
fälle wie den von frau bozen zu
verschweigen nicht zu thematisieren
ich bin fdp-politikerin ohne im
bundestag zu sein und ich denke
dass die
politik sehr vieles falsch gemacht hat
in den letzten zwei jahren es war die
erste pandemie und es gab sicherlich
viele neue herausforderungen und deshalb
ja ich stimme ihnen zu die politik hat
vieles falsch gemacht aber ob das jetzt
ein aktives verschweigen ist oder ob das
eben einfach fehlen einer fehlerkultur
ist werden wir klären müssen das machen
wir jetzt gerade auch in diesem sommer
aber das ist genau der punkt herr stöhr
war das leichtsinnig war das naiv wie
karl lauterbach der monatelang von
nebenwirkungsfreie impfung gesprochen
hat war dass leichtsinnig war das naiv
oder war das gezielt auch getäuscht um
nicht zusätzlich noch zu verunsichern
vor einer impfung die sowieso in weiten
teilen nicht angelaufen ist wie man sich
das gewünscht hatte ja die intention
dazu kann ich wenig sagen aber das
resultat war dass man tatsächlich auch
der arzt der die dann gesehen hat dann
offen sich der meinung war dass solche
dinge wirklich selten vorkommen oder
eigentlich gar nicht so zu beobachten
denn dann darf man auch nicht vergessen
dass der aufwand um so eine so ein
geschehnis zu dokumentieren hatte die
groß ist und ärzte arbeiten ja auch im
takt sie sind zwar alle gesetzlich wie
alle anderen mitarbeiter im
gesundheitswesen angewiesen solche fälle
zu melden aber es ist natürlich ein
aufwand sitzt manchmal 20 25 30 minuten
macht den ganzen papierkram und da sieht
man auch 23 patienten nicht also es gibt
eine infrastrukturelle probleme
sicherlich es gibt natürlich auch keine
erfahrung wenn man ein ganzes land impft
dann kommen natürlich unheimlich viel
nebenwirkungen natürlich muss man auch
erstmal absorbieren die infrastruktur
muss da sein und dann kommt das
natürlich auch dazu dass man vielleicht
verbal die leute auch nicht darauf
vorbereitet hat nicht nur darauf nicht
vorbereitet dass die impfungen nicht
jede infektion verhindert oder sogar
todesfälle nicht alle verhindern kann
sondern auch weil darauf verwandt ist es
wird nebenwirkungen geben und das beides
in der mischung zusammen glaube ich habe
mir mit naivität zu tun vielleicht mit
ignoranz als mit absicht aber dass
nebenwirkungsfrei hieß es halt ganz
lange in der politik hieß es von karl
lauterbach frau hätten sie solche fälle
wie den von frau putzen und haben sie
selber bei sich so im kopf vielleicht
bemerkt ja das ist kein thema für nur
corona leugner für querdenker sondern
ist ein breites gesellschaftliches thema
also kurz zudem dass karl lauterbach ja
sagte die impfung sei nebenwirkungsfrei
also mir fällt es schwer zu glauben dass
er davon ausging denn er ist arzt und
weiß natürlich dass jedes medikament und
jede impfung natürlich hat die
nebenwirkung deswegen war dieser tweet
am 14 ich habe damals auch kommentiert
und darauf hingewiesen dass natürlich
damit auch eine haftungsfrage einhergeht
hat ja auch zum beispiel geimpft also
wenn er so eine ähnliche aufklärung
nachbar hätte er hat das wider besseres
wissen wir wie es liegt nahe ich kann
das natürlich nicht so sagen und das
sage ich auch nicht aber es liegt sehr
nahe oder sehen sie alle nationen ein
arzt der vertrag sollte keine
approbation haben punkt 1 ein arzt der
sagt nebenwirkungsfrei ist die impfung
sollte keine approbation erreicht dafür
das heißt sie hätten das niemals getan
sie hätten zum damaligen zeitpunkt gar
nicht jedes medikament hatte
nebenwirkung jedes es geht gar nicht
anders aber es gibt keinen lebens
wirkungs freien impfstoff das ist weder
biologisch plausibel doch gibt es da
eine präsident präsident und man
suggeriert hier was falsches und es ist
genauso wie ein arzt aus meinem
blickwinkel eben einen zugelassenen
impfstoff auch verwenden sollte und er
kann sich nicht darauf berufen dass die
prozesse zur zulassung der impfstoffe
eben nicht perfekt sind das haben die
ärzte eigentlich im studium gelernt wie
die prozesse sind oder wenn man sich
damit die einfach stand erklärt ja dann
kann man gerne als werden jetzt genau da
ist der täuscht und also genau das ist
der aspekt wo man wo ich sah damals
schon den finger drauf gelegt habe und
auch jetzt sage dass man damit natürlich
als als gerade karl lauterbach hat viel
vertrauen erhalten und wurde
gesundheitsminister
damit geht eine hohe verantwortung
einher und wenn ich den menschen sagen
das ist nebenwirkungsfrei dann sage ich
damit natürlich so gerät damit da kann
auch nichts passieren und auf der
anderen seite und das ist das was ihnen
passiert ist hat das natürlich die
kehrseite gehabt dass das thema
tabuisiert wurde jede der bedenken
angemeldet hat modem oder geschrei auf
gemeinsam gegen die davon opfer quasi
wurden sind quasi zweimal dann opfer in
anführungszeichen geworden weil sie auch
dann jemanden gefunden haben der sie
ernst nehmen aber jetzt ist ja aber
entschuldigung ich hab mich gegen
so wird impfen lassen und habe eine sehr
schöne aufklärung vorher bekommen und
ich habe auch aufklärungsbogen bekommen
ist es nicht auch so dass tatsächlich
der der erwachsene mensch der also einen
arzt aufsucht auch schon eine abwägung
für sich trifft aber dann die frage an
frau wurden sie nicht aufgeklärt hatte
haben sie sich zu wenig informationen
geholt also ich hab natürlich diesen
aufklärungsbogen bekommen und ich habe
ja wie gesagt jedes mal auf vorher aktiv
das gespräch noch einmal mit den ärzten
gesucht natürlich auch unter dem aspekt
welchen einfluss hat das mal auf meinen
sport und wurde da halt aufgeklärt ich
kann sport nach einer woche wieder
machen und ansonsten habe ich aber
keinerlei nebenwirkungen zu befürchten
dass das jetzt irgendwie mich
einschränken würde
ich habe natürlich noch mal darauf
angesprochen auch dass es mir nach der
zweiten nicht so gut ging und ich auch
kurz davor noch mal erkrankt war und ich
hatte auch überhaupt nicht damit
gerechnet dass da so ein kalender auf
den punkt was hat der arzt dann in dem
moment ihr hausarzt oder jedenfalls was
hat er in dem moment gesagt verputzen
sie wollen mir doch nicht ernsthaft
erzählen dass sie jetzt angst vor der
impfung haben wir wie hat er reagiert so
so war es überhaupt nicht sondern halt
er so sie also einfach dieses sie
brauchen nicht zu befürchten dass es
dass es bisher noch gar nicht
vorgekommen ist dass da irgendwas
gemeldet wurde und dass ich den sport
auf jeden fall wenn ich jetzt eine woche
pausiere bei den astra zeneca über
impfungen war das sogar so dass sie
können am nächsten tag weiter machen was
ich natürlich nicht getan habe
bei der biontech dann fünf tage pausiert
habe ich dann eine woche ganz
eigenverantwortlich frau preißler frau
putzen hat sich die informationen alle
geholt hat gezielt nachgefragt und jetzt
hat sie leidet sie unter diesen folgen
die es laut karl lauterbach gar nicht
geben sollte und kann ihren sport nicht
mehr ausüben so wichtiger ist der
sendung nicht wahr also ich denke schon
wir wir müssen auch der jetzt den arsch
in der hose haben dann eben genau solche
solche
kommunikationsdesaster
zu besprechen zu sagen was hätte besser
laufen können was muss besser sein
können wir können wir im ablauf etwas
besser nach und zum beispiel auch wie
kann jemand der bei sich einen
impfschaden vermutet nebenwirkungen
vermutet wo kann der sich professionell
vorstellen damit dass man unsere hinter
und abgeklärt aber so weit sind wir
offensichtlich vielleicht hier am tisch
aber in der politik noch lange nicht wir
hören einmal rein was karl lauterbach
aktuell sagt angesprochen eben auf
dieses thema das der spiegel unter
anderem große aufgegriffen hat in dieser
woche zu impfschäden zu
impfnebenwirkungen mein eindruck ist er
tut es nach wie vor ab
das syndrom bezeichnet man ein syndrom
wonach der impfung die menschen sich
nicht so gut konzentrieren können wie
vorher oder wo also
nebenwirkungen vorkommen so ähnlich wie
bei costco witt allerdings seltener wir
seltener und auch weniger schwer vorher
habe er verharmlost also das muss man an
der stelle sagen das ist auch das was
jetzt von betroffenen ja auch schon kam
jetzt der jüngst im rbb interview mit
der journalistin genau die ada hat auch
gesagt sie fühlt sich verhöhnt ja und
dass das was sie gerade gesagt und da
bin ich ganz dabei das ist eine
verhöhnung also ich war ich war danach
fassungslos und ich mein ich tausche
mich auch mit anderen betroffenen aus
und es war wirklich wie ein schlag ins
gesicht weil wir kämpfen alle mit über
20 nebenwirkungen und zu sagen dass wir
uns nun nicht mehr so gut konzentrieren
können also wenn das seit einem halben
jahr mein einziges problem wäre dann
würde ich nicht darauf verzichten auto
zu fahren dann würde ich nicht weiß ich
nicht zwei drei mal die woche zu
verschiedenen ärzten 300 kilometer weit
fahren dann hätte ich keine 15.000 euro
arztrechnung behandlungskosten die ich
alle selber trage wenn es nur das wäre
und das zu verharmlosen
natürlich sind einige symptome wie post
co wird aber man muss halt auch sagen
dass einige sachen halt noch viel viel
schlimmer sind und wir halt zudem auch
noch diesen aspekt haben dass wir halt
gesellschaftlich verpönt sind also ich
glaub da sprechen sie zum beispiel auch
longo wird betreut aus dem herzen
allgemein haben wir eine gesellschaft in
der das thema corona mit ganz vielen
tabus belegt ist dass es gibt auch
menschen die hat eine sehr
sehr langwierigen sie gehören dazu frau
preis sie hatten einen längeren zu
müssen längeren corona verlauf sie haben
das sehr transparent sehr öffentlich
gemacht sie haben corona tagebuch
geführt im netz wir alle konnten also
über viele tage nachlesen wie es frau
preißler gerade mit ihrer corona
erkrankung geht sie waren in vielen
talkshows in dieser zeit warum haben sie
das gemacht warum haben sie das
öffentlich gemacht warum haben sie auf
die art und weise informiert
weil ich mit meiner familie transparenz
herstellen wollte es war eine krankheit
im märz 2020 die uns erwischt hat die
ganz vielen leuten suspekt war wir
könnten uns auch nicht aus ich bin nicht
vom fach und es kam ja also neben der
krankheit dann eben auch das thema wie
funktioniert isolation was macht man mit
gesunden und kranken in einem haushalt
und so weiter auf und zu wir haben
gesagt wenn wir uns als familie diese
frage stellen stellen sich andere die
auch und eben als politikerin will ich
einen dienst tun der irgendwas zum
gemeinwohl beiträgt und dann war meinen
dienst dann eben dieses corona tagebuch
und ich bin gottseidank vollständig
genesen so empfinde ich das aber ich
kenne ihn unfassbar viele leute die
gleich ja wie lange haben sie damit zu
schaffen gehabt auch als sie schon
wieder sozusagen gesund waren hatten sie
immer noch janko wird oder post co
wirklichen monate 18 monate das uns hier
ganz unterstellt ganz ähnliche geschäft
vorbei und frau preißler bei mir ging
das in wellen also ich hatte
sachen die gab es eben nur so temporär
eine sprachstörungen oder oder
geruchs verirrungen kam und gegen oder
so also ich kann es nicht sagen dass mir
18 monate lang schlecht wenig hat auch
sehr gute tage aber dieses gefühl und
aus diesem tal nicht mehr raus zu kommen
das macht einen schon basierten den
wunsch gehabt die impfung hätte es
früher gegeben dann wären sie
möglicherweise aus ihrer sicht nicht so
schwer erkrankt dass kann ich nicht
sagen ich kann nur sagen dass ich mich
danach wirklich mit freuden als astra
technikerin freigegeben wurde und ich
noch nicht dran warm ich habe dann
impfen lassen und für mich sagen muss
ich habe abgewogen ich möchte nicht noch
einmal diese krankheit haben ungeimpft
weil es war die hölle und wenn nicht das
risiko an einem schweren verlauf zu
erkranken
minimiert kann indem ich mich impfen
lasse ist das für mich der gute wille
das heißt sie würden sich jetzt im
herbst auch noch mal pusten lassen
selbstverständlich würden das auf gar
keinen fall und das mit ganz mit ganz
ähnlichen geschichten eigentlich mit
ganz ähnlichen symptomen auch heute das
ist faszinierend und hersteller die
politik hat ja ganz viel also zumindest
das gesundheitsministerium über longo
wird über post co wird gesprochen aber
ganz wenig über die ganz ähnlichen
symptomen offenbar von ja nach impfung
beschwerden ja dass das sind symptom
sieht ja sehr ähnlich aus und die anzahl
der menschen die davon betroffen sind
die sind ja auch noch nicht so genau
klar wie viel dann wieder ein oder auch
rom eigentlich nicht ja also in
deutschland sind natürlich vieles
schwieriger als in anderen ländern wo
man zum beispiel ein im register hat
dennis war hier gibt es im fall
registern vielen skandinavischen länder
da kann man auch dann sehr gut sehen wer
hat zum beispiel geimpft wurde und
welche anderen diagnosen gestellt wurden
in den folgenden wochen und monaten und
da kann man genau sehen ob diejenigen
die geimpft wurden zum beispiel
bestimmte diagnosen häufiger haben oder
das heißt sie könnten wahrscheinlich
noch nicht mal heute über den daumen
fallen wie fälle wie viele fälle frauen
frau bozen es in ganz deutschland heute
es gibt natürlich ein melderegister
jeder der im gesundheitswesen arbeitet
ist gesetzlich verpflichtet solche fälle
zu melden die werden dann in der
landesbehörde untersucht werden dann an
spy berichtet wird die statistik
durchgeführt hat wird jeder fall einzeln
austauschen
richtig gestellt jungs gibt es ja gerade
prozess ob soldaten und soldatinnen das
dulden müssen und da das
bundesverwaltungsgericht gesagt sie
sehen uns als erwiesen an dass es
sozusagen defizit bei den meldungen gibt
also von den krank von den ärzten und es
ist ja genau das was verputzen gerade
berichtet hatte dass der eigene art sich
ganz schwer tut das alles zu erkennen
und zur biologisierung aus der
wissenschaft und lassen sie mich
vielleicht nur sagen genau diese beiden
gruppen sind ja auch kommunikativ nicht
richtig angesprochen wurden man hat auf
der einen seite natürlich richtigerweise
gesagt wir haben eine impfung die kann
einer unheimlichen unterschied machen
das hätten sie gerne gesehen ich habe
ich auch bei mir gesehen ich habe vor
vier wochen habe ich mich infiziert
gehabt so einmal vorher geimpft ich habe
auch flach gelegen aber vielleicht wäre
es viel schlimmer geworden das ist gar
keine frage aber beide gruppen hätten
wenig erforscht also dass das würd mich
interessieren weil es dann häufig so
heißt also gibt es man kann ja so
zwillingspaare zwischen ungewöhnliche
ähnlicher status und so wird das erfolgt
weil das heißt ja immer dass dafür
brauchte man in deutschland eine
forschungskonzept dass ich eine
bundesregierung noch führungskraft
entsprechend entwickelt wurde sie sind
ja eher die mitglieder sollten jetzt
sind alle die das machen könnte die
durchführen aufsetzen sage ich jetzt
also ich habe damals nur global die
forschung geleiteten chor die natur eben
viele tausende institute beteiligt waren
und gibt es und biologische forschung
epidemiologische war schon klinische
forschung das ist eine riesen
mammut-aufgabe sowas zu organisieren
aber in deutschland gibt es natürlich
die strukturen dafür aber jetzt nochmals
zu den forschern feiert das glaub ich
das schnell auf das forschungskonzept in
deutschland hat nie richtig fuß gefasst
man hat also weder international noch
national die kräfte gebündelt versucht
die wichtigen epidemiologischen
biologischen unter klinischen fragen
herauszuarbeiten die vielleicht auch
finanzielle unterstützung benötigen um
dann eine konzentrierte priorisierte
solchen profil aktion vorzubereiten und
die post co wird und post impfung hätte
vielleicht auch mit dazu gehört aber
beides ist eben teil so einer pandemie
wir können um beide teile nicht
herumkommen es ist nur das thema da
offen darüber zu sprechen und schlüsse
daraus ja und das tun wir euch heute
sind ja knallharte versäumnisse also
dass man das nicht wissenschaftlich
begleitet hat bei dem als würde gerne
bleiben herrschte bei dem punkt würde
ich gerne bleiben denn sie sind jetzt
dem expertenrat der bundesregierung ich
würdige einfach gerne wissen war das
thema dort ist das thema bei der
auswertung bei der mehrere hundert
seiten dicken auswertung die wir in den
nächsten wochen bekommen ist ein großes
thema was hat die impfung eigentlich
gebracht was hat die für ein nutzen
gehabt und was hat die für risiken was
hat die auch für schäden gebracht ja ich
bin in der sachverständigenkommission
die an sich anschaut den paragrafen nach
dem infektionsschutzgesetz nicht immer
experten-gremium also genau das
letztendlich gibt zwei dinge also ich
worüber ich sprechen kann ist wie ich so
eine evaluierung sehen würde ich möchte
nicht darüber sprechen wie sie abläuft
das dauert noch ein paar tage aber aus
meinem blickwinkel müssten genau alle
interventionen die gemacht wurden allein
und in der kombination eingeschätzt
werden inwieweit sie infektionen
hospitalisierung todesfälle verhindern
und natürlich welche kollateralschäden
der wir wollen auf dem gesundheitlichen
im chart ist und auf eigentlich demokrat
wird das offen in den
sachverständigenrat diskutiert ist da
frau bozen beziehungsweise all die
frauen und herren putzen in deutschland
sind die ein thema dort also ich möchte
nicht über die interna sprechen haben
sie können sie gut vorstellen dass
natürlich haben wir uns zum beispiel die
sehr informative interventionen geht das
hat der konkreten analysiert wird welche
wirksamkeit die haben und da wird
geredet man natürlich auch über die
forschungs notwendigkeiten die forschung
slow sich keine deutschen in deutschland
die den daten mangel natürlich hat das
alles thematisiert aber was für mich
eben wichtig ist und bleibt dass man
jede einzelne maßnahme bindet an irland
dann seine oder ihre wirksamkeit was die
veränderung der todesfälle der infektion
betrifft dann kann man
gesundheitsökonomische evaluieren und
dann kann man auch zum schluss
verhältnismäßig ag und weil man dann
auch die maßnahmen vergleichen kann dann
kann man ja so wahnsinnig schwierig weil
man halt keine klare datenlage hat man
stochert nach wie vor im nebel weil
nicht genügend zahlen erhoben worden
sind und das ist der eindruck vieler
deutscher wir haben zum wochenende
einmal gefragt mit hilfe des
meinungsforschungsinstituts insa
bekommen sie eigentlich genügend
informationen über impfschäden über
impfnebenwirkungen und das ist das
ergebnis tatsächlich eine knappe
mehrheit der deutschen die aktuell sagt
ja also
wir bekommen genügend informationen
sagen 54,2 prozent ganz knapp ein
bisschen mehr menschen sagen in
deutschland also wir fühlen uns da nicht
ausreichend informiert durch die
bundesregierung das heißt anhand der
zahlen sieht man ja ganz klar frau habe
mit da ist was schief gelaufen den
vorgang ja und dafür braucht man
eigentlich auch keine umfrage weil das
liegt ja auf der hand also wenn man
sieht wie am ende frau preis hat ist so
schön gesagt das ist eine risikoabwägung
ich wäre für mich ab welches risiko ich
wähle und das muss auch nicht immer jung
sie für sich ab dass sie fragen mich
damit ob ich geimpft bin und ich würde
ihnen die frage auch beantworten aber
ich tu's nicht und zwar deswegen weil
mit der frage so viel mehr verbunden ist
als sie eigentlich sein sollte am ende
des tages ist es zu einem politikum
geworden
es ist eine gretchenfrage geworden sagt
wie hältst du es mit es gefährlich zu
sagen nein ich halte es nicht für
gefährlich es zu sagen ich halte es aber
für
eine eine frage die privat sein sollte
und die 1 sie haben gar keine hemmung
gerade gehabt mich das zu fragen wenn
gar kein star weil ich sowieso ganz
wenig hemmungen
aber ich wollte damit darauf hinaus dass
wir genau diese stärke für wieder
brauchen in der gesellschaft dass wir
wenn immer wenn wir ein gesundheits
nachweis um in einem restaurant zu gehen
vorzuweisen da muss man denken das kann
doch jetzt nicht wahr sein und dieses
gefühl das ist abhanden gekommen und das
wird immer das ist ein schleichender
prozess das ist so ein verschieben der
maßstäbe shifting baseline heißt das mai
2020 immunität aus weil sparen hat es
mal so reingeworfen alle gesagt auch
lauterbach auf gar keinen fall herbst
2021 selbstverständlich machen wir das
selbstverständlich 3g selbstverständlich
schließen wir ein teil der gesellschaft
aus und verhöhnen sie auch noch und
machen sie verächtlich und genau aus
diesem grund dürfen wir diese frage
meine ich nicht mehr stellen um all die
frage wieder dahin zu schieben wo sie
nämlich eigentlich hin allgemein finde
ich allerdings dass die debatte auf
sämtlichen seiten sämtlicher beteiligter
herum heftig geführte ja denn wenn es
also zu spüren bekommen frau preise ja
wobei ich die ja dass auch mir aussuchen
also auch meine profession gewählt habe
und also eben die dresche die ich
kassiere eben für die politik kassiere
die sich eben nicht auf die straße traut
oder eben nicht gerade dann vor ort ist
deswegen alles was ich kriege das ist
das hat schon auch irgendwo seine
berechtigungen wahren kern aber ich
stelle auch fest dass dieses ausgrenzen
und herabsetzen bei ganz vielen
beteiligten ist dann also wenn ich schon
wenn ich eben höhere was also
karabach seiner approbation verlieren
mensch wir hatten vorher glaube ich ein
bankmitarbeiter der
gesundheitsminister war also wir wer wir
sind wir sind schon dabei wir genießen
es einzelne persönlichkeiten eben auch
ganz besonders
herabzusetzen denn
wie gesagt jan sparen der mit masken
deals um noch ganz viel krassere
krasseren ding im gesundheitswesen ja es
war wirklich klasse als lang richtig
jedenfalls neben wirklich geil einfach
damit sagen dass dieses auf andere leute
mit dem finger zeigen und also sagt
nicht nur sie haben nicht nur auf der
sachebene anja greifen allgemein beliebt
geworden ist und
ich möchte auch ehrlich gesagt nicht
lesen und ich habe es gelesen ich hatte
mich darüber tierisch aufgeregt karl
lauterbach meinte er möchte man müsste
jetzt mal die zügel straff ziehen weil
bei uns bei uns müsste man jetzt mal die
zügel strafft ziehen damit wir alle
wieder in die spur kommen da war er noch
nicht minister und ich habe gedacht hey
ich ich und ich so im murisier der
emotionalisierung kommt natürlich auch
dadurch zustande dass es eben um
eingriffe in unser privates leben in
unser bis dahin privates leben geht sie
haben sich gerade dagegen massiv gewehrt
zu sagen das ist meine im status dabei
haben wir uns ja fast alle daran
gewöhnen müssen diesen status überall
mittlerweile zu zeigen ist neuestes
beispiel jetzt für diese eingriffe
impfung für unter fünfjährige mohammed
da müssen sie vielleicht erst mal den
herrn stöhr fragen also meines erreichen
meines erachtens ist es alles was das
thema impfung an land es muss eine freie
entscheidung sein das heißt ganz klar
die einrichtungs bezogene impfpflicht
die muss aufgehoben werden auch wenn das
bundesverfassungsgericht die abgesegnet
haben das heißt noch lange nicht dass
man daran festhalten muss ich halte
haben so viel unsicherheit haben
wir uns über das thema impfung für unter
fünfjährige herrschte ist das der
zeitpunkt um jetzt zu sagen wir gucken
uns noch kleinere kinder an und wollen
da gezielt jetzt rein in den herbst der
zeitpunkt ist ja impfstoff ist jetzt
zugelassenen usa dafür dass wir auch in
europa kommen also sich das anzuschauen
ist immer richtig die frage welches
nutzen-risiko-verhältnis wittmann und
wie wägen sie ab sie hat also man
braucht ein multidisziplinäres
expertenteam dass die weltliteratur
analysiert und dort sowohl den nutzen
als doch die riesigen neige geht es
nicht auch abonieren an also ist es
nicht kinder familien und
multidisziplinäre heißt natürlich auch
dass neben dem fachlichen dingen die da
evaluiert werden wo man nur die
gesundheitlichen aspekte
beurteilt und dann die empfehlung gibt
dann muss die politik sein die stiko
empfehlung die tragen wir nicht mit wenn
die das zum beispiel wollen dann sagen
wir aus familiären gründen machen wir
das nicht oder umgekehrt aber lassen wir
das mal so sagen was manchmal meine
überzeugung ist es ist ein mehr daten
jetzt dafür da dass die impfung auch bei
kindern auch jugendlichen besser
verträglich ist als man es
befürchtet auf der einen seite auf das
heißt dass zwischen risiko und nutzen
das risiko und ist dann nach unten
genommen auf der andere seite sehen wir
natürlich auch irgendwie kann natürlich
auch viel milde verläufe folge hat also
das verhältnis hat sich auf beiden
seiten verändert und dann muss man sich
das genau wieder anstatt es gibt bei
anderen impfstoffen die schon seit
vielen jahren auf markt und weil wir
influenza- impfstoffe die vor bei
kindern empfohlen werden von sechs
monaten ab in deutschland nicht in
vielen anderen da sein ja das dann was
man in kauf nimmt also wo man sagt okay
das bisschen risiko die paar kinder die
paar frau bozens die nehmen wir dann in
kauf also bei welcher grünen sind wir
das dann genau ist muss er das daher in
der leitung länger keine auch nicht
jeden verlieren dafür aber werden klum
gibt das kennen wir ja alle
sehr hat viele außer natürlich wenn die
eltern streiten also das darf man nicht
unterschätzen angenommen es gäbe eine
stiko empfehlung eltern sind sich uneins
wird das sechs oder sieben monate alte
kind geimpft
entscheiden richterinnen und richter was
man ja auch erstmal nachvollziehen kann
sowie die stiko empfiehlt also insofern
hat es natürlich auch eine rechtliche
komponente würden sie herr stöhr aber
dann noch mal konkret würden sie aktuell
in der kita impfen lassen also nochmal
ich bin nicht derjenige der reihe dort
machten die weltliteratur analysieren
kann einfach umfänglich ja wenn
gegenwärtige daten die ich kenne was ich
überblicke glaube ich dass das
nutzen-risiko-verhältnis bestenfalls
marginal ist und dass es keinen grund
jetzt gibt das zu favorisieren und dass
man sicherlich bei den kindern die vor
erkrankt sind eher geneigt sein kann das
zu unterstützen aber was eben wichtig
bleibt ist dass man sich auch andere die
wissenschaftlern hält und dass man da
nicht vorbei geht wie jetzt die
politiker
von mehreren fraktionen ja in den
letzten anderthalb bis zwei jahren
gemacht haben jetzt einzige wirklich
nach einem
strukturierten risiko system arbeiten
gremium neben der klinker dieser kranken
heutigen der kommission ist die stiko
ganz transparent machen die eine
risikoeinschätzung
das ist ein von der politik eigentlich
nur extrem wünschenswertes gremium dass
man sich auch geschaffen habe ich das
auch sagte sie habe mit der kita kinder
ein hohes ein höheres corona risiko aber
man darf nicht vergessen wer jetzt die
impro mächte für kita-kinder muss sie
für die nächsten jahrhunderte wollen
denn das wachsen ja immer wieder kinder
naiv nachgegangen geboren sind
immunologische naiv und andere als naiv
und müssen dann irgendwie sich
immunologisch mit dem virus arrangieren
aber das geht nur durch die infect
deswegen weil ihren kredit frage wie
hoch ist das korps ohne risiko für kita
kinder also kennen sie viele kita kinder
die an corona bei haben das
schwergewichtige verstanden das ist
nicht die richtige frau gefallen wie
viel ich kenne weil das das sind
natürlich statistisch wie viele seen
ortiz tisch kämen also doch gegenwärtig
liegen mehr kinder mit rsv dieser
respiratorische virus im krankenhaus auf
der intensivstation als mitbewohner ist
eine sehr seltene selten schwer
verlaufende infektion da gibt es
genügend pädiater die deutsche
gesellschaft für krankenhaushygiene dgkh
pädiatrische infektiologie haben auf
ihrer webseite die ganze statistik
berichten 30 prozent der deutschen
krankenhäuser die aktien sanken heute
kann man tagesaktuell schauen wie viel
kinder dort legen das ist sehr sehr
wenig und ich kann mir einfach nicht
vorstellen dass tatsächlich das risiko
der impfung
nicht die der infektion überschreitet
vor allen dingen wenn wir da einen
lebens sagen alle kinder impfen müsste
wenn alle kinder kommen naiv zur welt
und er jetzt möchte dass alle kinder
geben kann wir müssen ja auch nur
zukunft jedes jahr 100 millionen kinder
weltweit geboren ich will natürlich mit
watson auf einen punkt zu sprechen zu
kommen wenn wir über risiko und nutzen
sprechen dann geht es irgendwann auch
ums geld natürlich sie konnten ihren
sport nicht ausüben sie haben arztkosten
gehabt medikamentenkosten usw wer zahlt
die ihnen bisher
bisher übernehme ich den großteil selber
also es sind halt alles nicht anerkannte
behandlung ich habe immer ein globuli
therapie bekommen für 3000 euro die also
es ist ja keine anerkannte erkrankungen
demnach auch keine anerkannte behandlung
um ihr bruder hat gesagt das ist alles
jetzt test um wenn du das machen willst
dann freiwillig sagen sie ja frau habe
mit würden sie unterstützen sich sollten
sie also ich bin keine medizinrecht
lerin und deswegen betreue ich solche
fälle auch nicht so insofern würde ich
nicht machen weil besonders bitte die
kollegen und kolleginnen machen die die
deine experte aber wenn sie das hören
wollte eine gigantische kostenlawine auf
uns zu die unternehmen das wissen wir
übernehmen die kosten nicht die sind von
der haftung in dem fall ja
ausgeschlossen durch die verträge die
geschlossen wurden das heißt auf uns
alle auf uns steuerzahler rollte eine
riesige kostenlawine also juristisch
wird das problem vor allem seien die
kausalität nachzuweisen also insofern
und es ist gleichzeitig auch das problem
was betroffene haben ja weil
wahrscheinlich wird am ende des tages
nicht viele kosten das heißt verputzen
wird offiziell nicht geglaubt werde es
wird so sein keine frage des glaubens
war das auch keine frage glauben ist ob
das jetzt eine reaktion ist oder nicht
aber die kausalität fragen die eltern
mensch ist es so er sich jünger und
weniger vorher krank das duo aber da
wird es kosten die kosten aufzukommen
sind teil dieser naturkatastrophe
pandemie wenn man jetzt auch andersrum
denkt es keinen impfstoff gegeben hätte
dann wären die kosten unter umständen
weil ich hier viel höher ich klar das
problem ist nur dass frau putzen bisher
auf den kosten alleine sitzen bleibt und
wir an dem tisch einmal thematisieren
wollen wird es so bleiben oder gibt es
irgendjemand netterweise in der politik
der sich darum kümmern ich denke wir
müssen das thema angehen denn es ist ja
eben nicht nur frauen putzen das
betrifft ja ganz viele menschen ganz
offensichtlich und krone hat ja eben
hinterlässt er sehr viele leute leute
die mit tobit von longoria betroffen
sind die ihr gewerk nicht mehr ausüben
können die berufsunfähig wer via und die
genau die gleichen probleme mit der
kausalität haben wer ist dann schon in
der glücklichen situation zum beispiel
sich während der arbeit infiziert zu
haben so dass die berufsgenossenschaft
im augenblick seinen seinen
heilungsprozess ohr sein seine genesung
begleitet wer von uns ist ja es gibt ja
auch mediziner die erkranken und die
vorher an sehr hohen lebensstandard
hatten und jetzt seit ihrer infektion
eben nur noch auf dem letzten loch das
heißt die politik gilt aber auch damit
man nehme die kosten nicht tragen wo es
tut alles dafür dass man eben nicht
nachweisen kann dass watson ist dann
sogar ist das so ich glaube meine frage
ja genau also ich habe das auch so
verstanden wohlwollend als frage denn
ich denke es gibt sachen für die die
politik zuständig ist und dann gibt es
gott sei dank in unserem rechtsstaat mit
den verschiedenen zuständigkeiten eben
die gewaltenteilung und ich bin
eigentlich sehr froh denn genau wenn
jemand in diesen weg geht und dagegen
klagt und er sich um die kausalität
kümmern organe der rechtspflege ihn
vertreten dann bekommen wir ja
ergebnisse dann tatsächlich der himmel
habe dazu gehört auch eine politik die
den den weg insoweit ebnet dass das kein
tabu ist denn gerichte richterinnen und
richter sind menschen und die lassen
sich auch beeinflussen von einem
narrativ ist das so wir also
entschuldigungen ja sie tragen
einrichtungen
in der korona pandemie und doch einen
aus gerettet dann oft genug johannas wir
haben jetzt die politik oft genug
kritisiert ja und sie haben einige
sachen ganz gut gemeistert und bei
anderen nicht und wo sind diese fälle
dann gelandet
massnahmen nach dem
infektionsschutzgesetz weiter bei den
richterinnen und 3 dann in diesem land
und an der fülle der entscheidung die
ergangen sind und wo daneben auch die
kläger recht bekommen haben sehen wir
doch es ist ja dass
der freie richter eben durchaus seinen
job macht und darüber können wir alle
sehr froh sein dann wären wir wirklich
in einer corona diktatur dann wären die
sache nicht bei gericht gelandet dann
werden die leute wirklich montag ich
möchte sagen wir sind doch hier in
dieser situation dass wir alle hier
unsere auffassung vertreten können wir
kriegen alle hinterher drescher aber
niemand sagt dass das was ich äußere
unwidersprochen bleiben muss so ist doch
unsere gesellschaft
gleich zurück die die frage war mit
blick auf den fall von frau benutzen die
erkrankung von verputzen ob sie
überhaupt hilfe bekommt ob es überhaupt
herzige überhaupt anwälte gibt die sich
des themas annehmen oder ob die nicht
sofort das problem haben diese
schmutzige ecke in diese querdenker ecke
da will ich nicht rein das ist mir zu
heikel also bei den ärzten und ärztinnen
erscheint das ja so zu sein also was man
von betroffenen hört da werden sie
sicherlich auch realisiert werden sie
noch was dazu sagen so ich finde es
erstmal fatal das bis heute keine außer
eben jetzt marburg die natürlich jetzt
in einem hintersinn kleine ambulanz
gerne hätte die sich darum kümmern
keinerlei anlaufstellen gibt weil mit so
einer riesen werbekampagne zumindest
dachte ich das damals dass das halt mit
einhergeht bis ich halt selber betroffen
war und ich war also letztes jahr hat es
bei mir kein arzt gemeldet also ich war
bei stimme und ärzten und das ich glaube
dass das erste mal gemeldet wurde ich
kann es auch nicht sagen als ich in
marburg war und das war im april und
davon habe ich auch nur erfahren weil
ich mich mit anderen betroffenen
austauschen nicht weil irgendwie das
forderung ist ehrung für gesundheit auf
facebook oder solvaro diesen unmut nimmt
frau preißler mit in ihrem wahlkreis zu
ihrer politik zur fdp zu ihren ministern
und die nimmt auch herr stöhr mit nach
berlin zu den sachverständigen
diskutieren gleich weiter über neue
maßnahmen über die die politik im moment
ganz aktiv diskutiert zum beispiel über
die wiedereinführung der masken schlecht
von oktober bis ostern also das halbe
jahr der unmut ist riesengroß wie unter
anderem bei einem großen schlager star
den sie gleich in dieser sendung genau
mit diesem unmut erleben
[Musik]
zurück bei bild die richtigen fragen
rein in den corona herbst und da hören
wir dass die masken pflicht in vollem
umfang wieder zurückkehren soll in alle
innenräume von oktober bis ostern von
oktober bis ostern wirklich herr
lauterbach viele menschen machen das
nicht mehr mit wie auch er hier den
kennen sie ein bekannter schlager sänger
aus deutschland auf der bühne
[Applaus]
2600 könnte kommen
das ging ja auch die
berner bringt der schlagersänger hier
auf der waldbühne in berlin da einmal
groß auf holt auch mit der korona
politik und gegen karl lauterbach
schießt drückt das die stimmung im land
im moment ganz gut aus vor preißler wenn
wir über neue massnahmen richtung herbst
sprechen
ich denke es drückt die stimmung sehr
gut aus weil sie so losgelöst vom
infektionsgeschehen geführt wird also
sie haben ja schon angeht dieser sie
haben gesagt von oktober bis ostern
was ich sehr unlogisch finden denn
eigentlich müsste es heißen von oktober
bis ostern
sofern die infektions lage ist notwendig
macht dann ich finde es immer
übergriffig wenn etwas entschieden wird
ohne dass es dafür gute gründe gibt und
wir müssten eigentlich aus der
vergangenheit gelernt haben dass also
maßnahmen die nicht einleuchten sind
zu frust führen also bei mir zu gast in
mecklenburg verbrannt gab es eine
ausgangssperre und wenn ich nachts aus
dem haus gehe muss ich sowieso schon
ganz schön weit laufen überhaupt noch
jemanden zu finden also warum ich dann
durch eine ausgangssperre von einem
infektionsgeschehen geschützt sein muss
das leuchtet mir nicht ein wenn es nicht
einleuchtet gibt es krawall verstehen
sie herrn bringt einmal auf der bühne
sein frust raus lässt sich sagt das geht
uns auch gesagt ja ich habe mich der
einzige der den frust rausgelassen hat
was eben nicht funktioniert sind nicht
evidenzbasierte und nicht entsprechend
situation angepasste maßnahmen ja ich
meine wenn in schleswig-holstein nichts
los ist und in bayern die luft brennt
wegen krone da fragt man sich ja auch
warum soll man im bild fleisch oder
woanders dort okay das ist jetzt auch
direkt darauf dass masken pflicht da
waren wir nämlich gerade aber david es
basiert das ist ja die debatte des
wochenendes jahr angezettelt unter
anderem noch mal durch marco buschmann
der einen harmlosen satz gesagt hat im
zeitungsinterview du nicht gesagt hat
das brauchen wir nur dann wenn das
wirklich nützlich das ist der punkt ist
nämlich bei den stellt basiert nicht
verhältnismäßig oft weder angemessen
dass weder notwendig noch ist seine
verhältnisse das macht ja keinen sinn
die ganze zeit youtube es ist kalender
abhängig und das ist nicht auch den den
pandemie werden angepasst also man muss
jetzt wirklich nach dem was man im
herbst machen will das ist richtig man
hätte wochen stufen plan aber das kann
man auch über die mast nachdenken aber
nur eins sei auch ein bisschen tor zur
um das einzuordnen man hat ja vom
kanzleramt nicht gesagt wann macht dass
man hat gesagt man denkt darüber nach
also es ist ja
genauso dürfe nicht kommt ja aber es
wäre unvernünftig datenkalender
anzubinden und nicht an die
entsprechende situation
wie handhaben sie dass frau putzen
tragen sie ihnen auch wenn ich fragen
darf maske zum beispiel im supermarkt da
ist es immer so er eine spaltung wie ich
das noch erleben die einen seit wochen
mittlerweile ohne ganz viele aber weiter
konsequent mit maske wie handhaben sie
das also so an sich ich gehe kaum noch
selber einkaufen also ich lasse das
alles erledigen und nicht gehen sondern
sich auch nicht mehr
großartig raus am anfang also als es
dann hieß masken pflicht fällt weg habe
ich natürlich gemacht einfach um mich
selber zu schützen also
gar nicht großartig um irgendwie jetzt
andere zu schützen sondern einfach weil
ich in meinem zustand nicht noch mit
irgendwas krank werden wollte sei es
jetzt corona oder erkältung aber
mittlerweile weil ich halt diese luft
probleme habe mache ich ihn auch nicht
mehr haben sie den eindruck haben wir
haben überhaupt ernsthaft die wahl also
am supermarkt vorne steht weiter die
empfehlung drauf karl lauterbach sagte
letzt am freitag dringende empfehlung
bitte maske tragen obwohl wir keine
masken pflicht haben ist das eine völlig
freie entscheidung im moment also freier
als sie die impfung war das würde ich
schon sagen das erlebe ich tatsächlich
auch so dass menschen sich am anfang
sehr zögerlich aber jetzt würde ich
sagen also die mehrheit deutliche
mehrheit trägt eben keine maske mehr und
zu dem was sie gerade sagt also die
frage masken pflicht dass das scheint
das ist ein grundproblem dieser corona
politik dass man mit bürgern und
bürgerinnen spricht als wären sie
ungünstig ja man möchte ihnen zügel
anziehen sie haben vorher eben gesagt
diesen erzieherischen gedanken warum
denn eine pflicht warum denn keine denn
eine gut sitzende maske die man wie man
richtig trägt daran scheitern hersteller
bmw fdp trägt es am ende mit wieder da
wird irgendwie klar oder behände
unterschreibt der lindner ich sage oder
abwarten meinen lieben ich bin nämlich
der festen überzeugung dass also masten
tatsächlich
schützen und ich trage sie wirklich
gerne und ich trage sie sitzen und dann
können sie alle machen was sie wollen
wenn sie finden sie können ohne maske
einkaufen gehen einverstanden ich bringe
die einkäufe wenn sie in fünf tagen alle
krank sind aber ich denke die fdp hat
gerade in den vergangenen monaten
richtig guten job gemacht und sie hat
uns vor der allgemeinen pflicht bewahrt
und sie wird weiter aufklären und
informieren und ich finde er
hat das gemacht ist dafür massiv erhöht
worden verbal auch aus den eigenen
reihen dass das kann ja gut ab diese
glocke aber ich muss ihnen auch sagen
dass wir
der meinung sind denke ich in der fdp
dass die impfungen gut ist aber die
impfentscheidung in frei sein sollte und
wäre hält auch für die einrichtungs
beziehung leben vielleicht muss es nur
mal noch erwähnen weil das gesamte noch
ganz oft gesagt
aber da ist ja der haken erstmal
zumindest daneben pflegt kommt nicht das
ist aber jetzt machen wir strahlen auch
obersten pflicht an spricht ja verliert
völlig aus dem gesichtsfeld wo wir uns
befinden also wir sind sommer niedriger
infektion zur geringe infektions
wahrscheinlichkeit und dann noch zu
empfehlen dass ich jetzt hier den
vierten buchstaben wurden also hin und
herschwanken einer sommer welle ist ja
sagt cfo
empfehlen genau bevor werde ich jetzt in
vielen vierten booster zu nehmen heißt
es heißt dass man den empfiehlt auf den
fünften zu nehmen damit ich mich jetzt
impfen das würde ich mich über 60 dann
würde ich mich im herbst noch mal impfen
lassen müssen weil natürlich ein spätes
weit über das ist interessant oder eine
70-prozentige bessere schutz gegen die
infect das uns interessant herr
lauterbach spricht genau sie an er meint
genau sie in der pressekonferenz vom
freitag er meint genau ihre altersgruppe
er meint genau jemanden der wie sie zb
hier in dieser talkshow wieder mal viele
kontakte hat er meint genau sie und er
empfehlen jetzt lassen sie sich bewusst
ich habe gesehen
und dann sitzt der trotzige der bockige
klaus stöhr sitzt hier und sagt herr
lauterbach das mache ich ja nicht
endlich hier ich habe zwar ein breites
kreuz aber das macht er nicht wir das
wichtiger ist welche kommunikation bei
den menschen ankommt eben nicht so viel
ahnung vom thema haben wie ich davon ab
und schauen sie mal im februar märz
april war unsere gesundheitssystem nicht
überlastet gewesen großflächig und da
war noch viel weniger menschen geimpft
war viel weniger menschen infiziert und
warum spreche ich dann jetzt im herbst
wo viel mehr menschen da noch geschützt
sind darüber dass ich jetzt schon masken
tragen möchte wenn im prinzip die
situation sich höchstwahrscheinlich noch
weiter entschärfen also man setzt ein
völlig falsches signal man
kompromittiert vielleicht auch eine gute
maßnahme masten helfen ja auch mal
kompromittiert diese maßnahme jetzt in
dem man schon wieder feuer feuer ruft
und im herbst wird dann keiner mehr
darauf was hat das mit ihnen gemacht
frau preis am freitag wie der
pressekonferenz die ganze woche die karl
lauterbach von sommer welle spricht
übrigens nachdem er wenige wochen vorher
noch gesagt hat die sommer welle wird
nicht gefährlich werden jetzt kommt die
sommer wenn er schränkt zwar ein ja ja
erst hinterher aber trotzdem dieses wort
macht ja mit einem was sommer welle was
macht es mit ihnen ich finde es ganz
interessant dass sie auch schon
differenzieren zwischen dem den
umständen und der wortwahl weil
tatsächlich haben wir einen sommer werde
ich kenne unfalls noch viele leute um
mich herum die gerade eben an krone
erkrankt sind also wir können die fakten
nicht leugnen corona ist da passiert und
die leute werden krank und haben
unterschiedlich schwere verläufe
entscheiden und er auch dass schmerzen
nur oder ich bin keine medizinerin
deswegen sage ich dazu auch nichts aber
ich finde die sprache macht enorm was
dann tatsächlich dieses ständige feuer
feuer feuer feuer rufen bringt uns dazu
dass wir irgendwann schon zur neuro ene
auf durchzug schalten müssen weil wir
einfach nur einen gewissen anteil an
warnungen schlechten botschaften
aushalten können dann wir haben eben wir
müssen eben unser leben meistern und
deswegen glaube ich auch dass also
die beratungs oder seine beratung
vielleicht nicht die beste ist denn
dieses nachts twittern und alarm alarm
und eine pressekonferenz ich wünschte
mir tatsächlich von meinem minister dass
er mehr im ministerium ist man sich auch
noch mehr themen beleuchtet also diese
wäre diese bibel diskutieren jetzt über
eine maske schlecht ist müssen wir auch
weil es steht zu befürchten dass die
irgendeine art und weise kommen
eigentlich müssen wir aber über exit
strategien sprechen wir müssen darüber
sprechen wie wir wieder zu einem
normalzustand kommt denn wenn wir jetzt
mit einer allgemein masken pflicht im
herbst weitermachen werden wir sie nicht
mehr los naja ich drehe mich nicht mehr
ökologie schokolade ullmann hat im
winter 2020 gesagt wir könnten doch
dabei auch impfung hatte gerade erst
angefangen und so weiter die aha + l
regel die könnte man doch im winter
immer machen und zwar im dezember
zweiter ist das ist ein interessanter
punkt das heißt mittlerweile sagte
lauterbach naja masken vielleicht wenn
wir die halt da haben dann im herbst von
o bis o also von oktober bis ostern dann
schützt die auch vor anderen schweren
infektionen dann haben wir das verstört
dann schützt das eben auch von einem von
einer sonstigen grippe von erkältung
vielleicht auch vom magen darm infektes
verhältnismäßig das ist die frage und
empfangen und er seine 370 stimmen im
bundestag mehr so sein herz mariens
nochmal ich schreibe der fans ist das
ist nicht nur ist die frage wer erklärt
jetzt die verhältnismäßigkeit da sagt
die bundesregierung immer weiter haben
wir keine zahlen zu ich kann ihnen auch
nicht sagen es ist die englische sahen
loose cannon will jemand der im prinzip
nicht so zu steuern ist für jemand der
als bundesminister egal wo er sitzt
kommuniziert würde ich mehr
bodenständigkeit
verantwortungsbewusstsein strategie
langfristiges denken erhoffen und mehr
auch eine bessere vorbereitung denn
nicht nur pressekonferenz geben keine
panik sondern redet nicht so schlimm
aber vielleicht wenn man ruhigen sommer
haben will sollte man sie vielleicht
impfen lassen aber vielleicht nur die
über irgendwas war danzig warschau alle
noch einmal konkret herrschte was muss
gegeben sein damit auch sie sagen würden
im herbst brauchen wir tatsächlich
masken pflicht also was wäre die
entsprechende evidenz dafür ja man
brauche jetzt ein stufenplan der
parameter die wichtigsten da würden
seinen krankenhauseinweisungen kann muss
bewegung und intensivstation belegung
und diese parameter würde man bin dann
bestimmte situation bei 15% 20% 15% und
dann würde man bestimmte maßnahmen dann
weil ich sie jetzt aktuell dort aus also
blicke einmal ganz schnell lief
sachsenhäuser ja in berlin liegen
weniger als 40 leute auf einer
intensivstation lenkt oder in
deutschland ist relativ hohe man kann so
wie man sich nur hoffen kann für ein
sommer aber noch mal brauchen stufen
plant er jetzt transparent auch mit der
gewissen ich sag mal positiv agenda für
den herbst den leuten zeigt was gemacht
werden müsste wenn das allgemeinwohl
belastet also wenn die gesundheits wenn
die krankenhäuser nicht mehr so
weitermachen können nur wenn dieser
stufen plan vorlegt sind müsste man auch
genau wann diese maßnahmen wieder
abgebaut werden würden interessant ist
dass es in vielen anderen ländern so
überhaupt nicht diskutiert wird wie in
diesem das eigentlich man entspannt den
sommer genießt einfach dass man auch
richtung herbst in spanien in portugal
selbst wo die zahlen hoch gegangen sind
recht entspannt richtung herbst schaut
und nicht über neue masken pflicht über
neue massnahmen diskutiert warum es gibt
also es ist es ist irgendwie es ist eine
art obsession ich kann es mir nicht
anders erklären und sie entkoppelt sich
auch völlig von der realität wenn sie
nennt ist das ist das grundproblem was
wir haben und zum thema
verhältnismäßigkeit es ist unterstellt
evidenz also auch auf
also nicht nur individuell sondern eben
auch auf die ganze gesellschaft bezogen
angenommen es gibt eine entsprechende
evidenz für die massen wieder muss man
sich trotzdem die frage stellen ist das
verhältnismässig ist das und das ist
eine rein juristische frage jetzt
erstmal die zuallererst die der
gesetzgeber zu beantworten hat denn er
entscheidet sich wie es rechtlich löst
oder wie es gesetzlich löst oder nicht
und danach ist in die gerichte an der
dran und müssen dann überprüfung ist das
licht aus ihrer sicht aus ihrer
juristischen sicht aktuell noch
verhältnissen ist meines erachtens ist
sie in der also eine allgemeine masten
blick für die
für die bevölkerung im allgemeinen die
ist nicht mehr verhältnismäßig nein auch
nicht im bus und bahn zum krater
bestimmt genau und zwar aus folgendem
grund etwas anderes gilt für variable
einrichtungen aber bei warum ist sie
nicht mehr verhältnismäßig die maske
wenn sie jeder hat die möglichkeit sich
selbst zu schützen mit impfungen maske
abstand halten sonstiges es gibt
behandlungsmöglichkeit so das heißt wir
haben ein lebensrisiko eines mehr es
gibt viele anderen auch das heißt wir
müssen sind jetzt in der situation wo
wir individuell mit diesen lebensrisiko
umgehen müssen und auch
zwischenmenschlich sinnvoll wenn ich
jetzt weiß ich bin in der truppe wohl
lauter ältere menschen sind und wir sind
im innenraum lässt ich mich natürlich
vorher ja das ist sinnvoll aber da
brauche ich keinen staat der mir das
sagt und auch die maske da brauche ich
auch keinen staat der mehr dass sie
nicken er stört das heißt sie würden
auch sagen mit blick auf die nächsten
monate supermarkt sowieso nicht
evidenzbasiert braucht man nicht
öffentliche verkehrsmittel auch keine
sind auch evidenz mit
verhältnismäßigkeit evidenz sei hier
kann ich jetzt nicht so viel wie derzeit
seien viel genauer verhältnismäßigkeit
das eigene verantwortung auch extrem
wichtig denn sie hat schon ganz
großartig gesagt wenn sie irgendwo
hingeht wohl gerade sich aufhalten
tasten sie sich vorher frau hamid und so
sehe ich das mit der maske auch wenn wir
uns weiter im supermarkt treffen trage
ich nur masken sie nicht ich finde ich
ok einverstanden für mich ist die masse
des masten tagen im sommer die
verlängerung zum in dem dnt wir werden
uns ja alle infizieren das ist ja völlig
farblos es ist schlechterdings nicht
möglich vor dem virus sich zu verstecken
es wird passieren und wir haben ein
stabiles gesundheitswesen wir haben
impfstoff mit nebenwirkung und es gibt
gute medikamente viel besser als mehr
erhoffen konnte und jetzt wird sich
jeder infizieren und wer jetzt die
infektion noch nach hinten schiebt
nachdem man sich hoffentlich geimpft hat
schiebt das indem ibm den nach hinten
also wer jetzt auch diese infektion
nicht zulässt verschiebt diese infektion
in dem herbst ein stein
an die prävalenz sich auch verlängert
dann ist es auf lokalen gruppen sogar
gefährlichen sterben gegebenen fall
müsste sich der radler gruppen auch
selber schützen sollen die auf
eigenverantwortliche handeln müssen
hersteller als theaterstadt sicherlich
der verantwortung ich finde es ja auch
nicht schlecht weil es ja mit auto
brachten
pressekonferenz jetzt vorgeschlagen dass
man in den eigenen pflegeheim
verpflichtend hygiene beauftragte 1 das
hätte man vor zwei jahren 40 prozent der
todesfälle in den letzten zwei jahren
waren gab sie den
altenpflegeeinrichtungen und nicht bei
den nicht bei den kindern und da hat man
mit dem rasenmäher prinzip hat man alle
gleich behandelt und sie hat man
vergessen dass man das jetzt richtig
macht finde ich gut zum beispiel aber
wenn man jetzt die infektion nach hinten
schiebt dann gibt es natürlich
infektionen die ausstellung cupid führen
da gibt es auch schwere erkrankung wird
gibbs todesfälle aber es ist so als
diese dann können wir die fläche unter
der kurve ist gleich wie kann denn so
spitz sein und kurz oder lang und flach
aber die leute die erkranken und sterben
werden werden die anzahl dieser engine
leider das ist bei so einer tour
phänomen zu haben über die massen
pflicht diskutiert hier in dieser runde
wir haben über die impfung diskutiert
und wir haben das auch mit verputzen
getan an diesem tisch die nachricht vor
wie sie sagt unter den folgen dieser
letzten impfung vor allen dingen zu
leiden hat wann hoffen sie wann glauben
sie wann rechnen sie damit wieder voll
bei kräften zu sein und tatsächlich auch
ihren leistungssport ihren dreikampf
wieder voll ausüben zu können ich hoffe
dass ich dieses jahr auf jeden fall noch
wettkämpfe machen kann weil ansonsten
bin ich erstmal aufs denke ich aus dem
nationalkader
aber da mir auch kein arzt sagen kann
was in meinem körper ab geht und welche
behandlung helfen kann ich leider nur
abwarten deutsche meisterin nämlich die
hoffentlich bald wieder ihren titel
verteidigen kann wieder gewinnen kann
und möglicherweise noch nach höherem
streben kann vielen dank frau danke frau
hat dann gestern an chrysler für eine
lebendige diskussion hierbei bild die
richtigen fragen wir sind zurück
nächsten sonntag
[Musik]